president trump described justice
ginsburg as quote a fighter to the end
he reacted to her death as he left a
campaign rally in minnesota last night
both he and his election opponent former
vice president joe biden
campaigned in the hotly contested state
on friday
today the president campaigns in north
carolina and with the death of justice
ginsburg a new election issue
nicole killian is in fayetteville north
carolina to continue our coverage
nicole good morning
good morning to you michelle and news of
justice ginsburg's passing broke during
president trump's
rally last night he went on for nearly
two
hours before he became aware of what
happened
he is expected to campaign here in
fayetteville later today but
make no mistake this changes the dynamic
of the race
from the white house and capitol hill
where flags were lowered at half staff
to the steps of the supreme court as the
nation learned of justice ruth bader
ginsburg's death
so did president trump moments after
stepping off the stage at a minnesota
campaign rally
she just died wow
i didn't know that i just could tell you
me now for the first time
actually sad to hear that the president
released a fuller statement calling
ginsburg a titan of the law
renowned for her brilliant mind and her
powerful dissents at the supreme court
all of the former living presidents
offered condolences
bill clinton who nominated ginsburg to
the high court in 1993 wrote
her 27 years on the court exceeded even
my highest expectations when i
appointed her her landmark opinions
moved us closer to a more perfect union
former vice president joe biden said it
was an honor to preside
over ginsburg's confirmation hearing
ruth bader ginsburg
stood stood for all of us fresh off his
own campaign stop to minnesota
he made clear her replacement should be
decided after the election
this was the position of the republican
senate took
in 2016 when there were
almost 10 months to go before the
election
that's the position the united states
senate must take today
today i am nominating chief judge
merrick brian garland
many democrats are still reeling after
the gop-led
senate passed over obama nominee merrick
garland
the president has already named two
justices to the bench friday night he
touted his latest list of potential
candidates
we have about 45 unbelievable people
humble of the smartest the best
the absolute creme de la creme right
the best minds in the country
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
said president trump's nominee
will receive a vote on the senate floor
although he did not specify a timetable
but trying to do this before the
election
could be tricky on average it takes
about 69 days to get through the
confirmation process and
there's just 45 days left until the
general election
dana nicole thank you